Game of Thrones Season 8 Episode 4 starts
with the living mourning the dead.
Daenerys cries over Jorah – her loyal friend
and protector.
Sansa cries over Theon, and puts a Stark pin
on his Greyjoy armour.
Theon never felt accepted by either family
in life, but in death, he’s a Greyjoy and
a Stark . Beric, Edd, Lyanna, Qhono, and thousands
of others died in the Long Night, including
some hundred thousand zombies – who all
were once men women and children.
Jon gives a speech and says everyone “set
aside their differences” to fight together
– but soon, division and suspicion set in,
and a new war takes shape.
After all the death, the living celebrate
life, with food drink and sex , in that order.
Daenerys speaks with Gendry – the bastard
son of the old king, Robert Baratheon.
All the Baratheons are dead now, so Dany decides
to legitimise Gendry – to legally remove
his bastardy.
She makes him Gendry Baratheon, Lord of Storm’s
End . This is a common strategy in Game of
Thrones – you give someone a position of
power that they owe to you, and you’ve made
yourself a powerful ally.
So Daenerys calls this a “clever” move
, but legitimising Gendry is risky – he’s
the son of a king, so Gendry or his children
could potentially make a claim on the Throne.
Like, a hundred years ago, the Targaryens
legitimised the bastard Blackfyres, which
led to a series of rebellions that lasted
for generations . Gendry might not rebel,
but any of his descendants could.
The Lord of Storm’s End rules the Stormlands,
one of the Seven Kingdoms of Westeros.
So Gendry is now one of the most powerful
politicians on the continent – which is
crazy, cause as Gendry says, he doesn’t
know how to be a lord, he hardly knows “how
to use a fork” . This is also a reminder
that the Seven Kingdoms exist.
Westeros is a feudal society, ruled by hierarchy
of lords, and in early seasons, the story
focussed on the families who ruled each kingdom.
But now the kingdoms seem irrelevant – no
one even seems to know who rules them .
Tyrion and Davos talk about the Lord of Light,
the fire god worshipped by Melisandre.
It seems as though the Lord helped win the
war against the white walkers – his magic
lit the trenches and the arakhs, and guided
Mel to send Arya at the Night King.
It’s said that his magic resurrected Jon
and Beric , gave Daenerys her dragons , gave
the Hound a vision, and had some great destiny
planned for them all.
But now, Davos says, the Lord of Light “fucks
off” with no explanation – so what was
the magic and destiny stuff all about?
Tyrion says thinking about this won’t make
you happy , which is like a meta message to
the audience, saying the gods and magic and
prophecies in the story won’t be explained,
so don’t think about it.
Tyrion speaks with Bran, and Bran says that
his wheelchair is based on a specific historical
wheelchair – as the three-eyed raven, Bran
can see all of the past and present . It’d
be nice if he revealed something useful, like
Cersei and Euron’s military movements, but
instead Bran talks about wheelchairs.
He says he mostly lives in the past, and he
doesn’t “want” any more . Becoming a
magic wheelchair encyclopedia has caused Bran
to lose his humanity . Tyrion says that Bran’s
knowledge would make him a good ruler . And
Varys later says that the best ruler might
be someone who doesn’t want to rule , and
Bran doesn’t want.
If the show wants to be really surprising,
they could end with Bran on the Throne.
Strangely, Bran has been a favourite on betting
sites for months now – maybe someone knows
something.
And like, how else will Bran’s story end?
If he won’t rule Winterfell , and won’t
be a tree man , maybe he’ll be king.
Tormund talks up Jon, saying he’s a great
leader, cause Jon is strong, makes allies,
rides dragons, and doesn’t afraid of anything.
And Daenerys is upset.
Cause she’s a strong leader and a dragonrider,
and she’s been doing it for six seasons.
She sacrificed half her armies, friends and
a dragon saving the north, and yet she’s
still not getting the love and loyalty that
she needs.
This is similar to when Dany’s brother Viserys
was jealous of Dany for the loyalty she got
in Season 1 . Viserys reacted with rash angry
violence which led to his death – the show
might be hinting at a similar fate for Daenerys.
Tormund says that dragonriders are either
kings or madmen – Jon is framed as a king,
and Daenerys as a madman.
And yeah there’s also a coffee cup in the
shot, which is either a production mistake
or the smartest product placement ever.
Tyrion Jaime and Brienne play Tyrion’s drinking
game from Season 1, where you have to guess
truths about each other.
Tyrion guesses that Brienne is a virgin , and
she gets uncomfortable and leaves.
Jaime goes after her, breaking the heart of
poor Tormund.
He has a massive crush on Brienne, but a serving
girl comes to cheer him up instead.
Pod the Rod picks up two girls – he’s
made a reputation for himself.
The Hound speaks with Sansa.
Last time they saw each other, Sansa was a
scared naïve girl, and the Hound was fleeing
battle.
He had offered to take Sansa with him, but
she refused – and ended up with Littlefinger
and Ramsay . Sansa says that her experiences
made her the person she is now . She learned
from some of the worst people in Westeros,
and their manipulative methods and cruelty
have rubbed off on Sansa.
She smiles about having Ramsay torn apart
by dogs , just as Ramsay smiled when he had
people killed by dogs . And Sansa’s scheming
this episode to undermine Dany is totally
Littlefinger’s style .
While everyone else has fun together, Arya
is alone, training.
Gendry comes and asks her to marry him, to
“Be the Lady of Storm's End” . But Arya
says she’s “not a lady”, that’s not
her , which is a reference to Season 1 – Arya
never wanted to marry a lord and have ten
kids in a castle so she turns Gendry down.
This is similar to when Gendry’s father
Robert loved Arya’s aunt Lyanna.
Lyanna was a rebellious adventurous girl like
Arya, and Robert was a Baratheon warrior with
a hammer like Gendry.
Lyanna didn’t love Robert back – she ran
off with Rhaegar and had Jon instead, and
so Robert started the war that took down the
Targaryens.
Tyrion says that the last 20 years of war
traces back to Robert and Lyanna.
So hopefully Gendry takes rejection better
than his father did.
Jaime comes to Brienne’s room and uses the
classic it’s-too-hot-in-here-for-clothes
move . There’s been sexual tension with
these guys since Season 3, and now they finally
consummate their love.
They’re both awkward and shy – this is
Brienne’s first time, and it’s Jaime first
time with anyone other than Cersei.
Jaime and Brienne have never had healthy sexual
relationships before, and Jaime ultimately
can’t handle it.
When he hears that Daenerys is closing in
on Cersei, Jaime leaves Brienne and rides
south.
Brienne begs him to stay, says he’s a good
man, and he doesn’t need Cersei . But Jaime
feels defined by his crimes.
He crippled Bran, killed his cousin, and threatened
Riverrun, all to be with Cersei.
Cersei represents Jaime’s failures and flaws,
and he feels he can’t escape her, or change
the hateful man that he really is . So has
Jaime redemption arc failed?
Jaime’s story isn’t as simple as a bad
guy becoming a good guy.
Author George Martin says that Jaime’s arc
explores the limits of redemption, whether
it’s even possible to be forgiven for crimes
so horrible . Brienne believes in Jaime, but
Jaime doesn’t believe in himself.
Maybe he’ll return to Cersei and to her
hateful ways.
Or maybe this about confronting Cersei.
Maybe Jaime will redeem himself by facing
his evil twin, his darker half.
The books hint that Jaime might kill Cersei.
But he might die in the process.
Jaime and Cersei believe that they’ll die
together .
This is also awful for Brienne.
One of the defining moments in her backstory
was being mocked and betrayed by boys who
pretended to like her.
Now she’s suddenly dumped by the first man
she ever made love with.
Brienne has won respect as a knight, but will
she ever get love?
Maybe she’ll follow Jaime south, and play
a role in the final confrontations.
Jon and Daenerys get their fuck on, until
they remember that Daenerys is Jon’s aunt.
Jon’s real name is Aegon Targaryen, and
he has a better claim on the Throne than Daenerys
does.
So Dany’s worried that people will want
him to rule Westeros instead of her – she
saw how people love him as a leader.
And even if Jon refuses the Throne, he could
be used against Dany.
So she begs him to keep his identity secret
, but Jon says he has to tell his family the
truth.
Ned Stark kept the secret of Jon’s parents
all his life . But now Jon is determined to
reveal it, even though it could destroy his
relationship with Dany and his family.
The war against Cersei is planned.
Apparently, only half of the Unsullied, Dothraki
and northmen died last episode . It had looked
like most everyone died, but apparently the
zombie apocalypse weren’t so apocalyptic
after all.
Cersei has the Golden Company, twenty thousand
mercenary soldiers.
Daenerys has the north and the Vale, and now
she has the Iron Islands and Dorne, thanks
to Yara and a new Dornish Prince.
So Daenerys is in a strong position.
She just needs to find a way to remove Cersei
without killing innocent people in King’s
Landing – Cersei is using civilians as a
meat shield.
Tyrion and Jon suggest putting the city under
siege and starving the people until they rise
up against Cersei . Which is a pretty bad
plan.
Cersei blew up the pope in Season 6.
She murdered hundreds of innocent people,
including the Faith, the beloved Tyrells,
and her own uncle, and everybody including
Hot Pie knows she did it . Cersei has no claim
on the Throne, she hates the people, and the
people hate her , so surely if the people
were gonna rise up, they already would’ve.
And sure, maybe starving the people will motivate
them, but that defeats the whole purpose of
taking the city without hurting innocents.
A much better solution to the Cersei problem
is standing right there.
Arya is a highly trained Faceless assassin.
Last season, she infiltrated the Twins, wore
Walder Frey’s skin, and wiped out a whole
house.
Surely she could sneak in and kill Cersei.
Next to Arya is Bran, the guy knows everything
and can scout with ravens.
Also present is Davos, who smuggled Tyrion
into the Red Keep last season.
These characters defeated the apocalypse last
episode – surely they could use their skills
to kill Cersei safely.
And if nothing else, they could just attack
King’s Landing normally with soldiers, and
try to minimise casualties, like every other
battle Daenerys has fought.
This expectation that Dany has to capture
the capital gently is unreasonable.
It’s a plot contrivance to make Dany choose
between two extremes – will she find a peaceful
solution, or will she “Burn them all”
like her father before her?
Sansa and Arya confront Jon, and say they
don’t trust Daenerys.
They don’t want their home and their family
subject to a foreign dragon queen.
And Sansa doesn’t want Jon to march south
– there’s a history of Starks going south
and not coming back . But Jon says he’s
not a Stark – he reveals the truth, that
he’s a Targaryen.
So this separates Jon from the Starks – is
he still part of the family?
Jon was Arya’s favourite brother growing
up because they were both misfits – Arya
a tomboy, and Jon a bastard.
But now it turns out Jon wasn’t a bastard,
and wasn’t her brother – he’s a Targaryen
cousin.
This could distance Jon from his sisters – though
the scene cuts so we don’t see their reactions.
Jon makes his sisters swear to keep his secret
– swearing in front of a heart tree has
religious significance.
But Sansa breaks her vow and tells Tyrion
– because Sansa wants Jon on the Throne
instead of Daenerys . Tyrion tells Varys,
and the scheming begins, so Jon’s secret,
and Sansa’s oathbreaking, threatens to divide
Daenerys Jon and the Starks.
Arya rides south with the Hound, and she says
she won’t go back . Recently, Arya declared
she was a Stark of Winterfell , but now it
seems she’s rejecting her family and home
– maybe partly because of Jon’s revelation.
Arya says she has “unfinished business”
, which probably means killing Cersei and
the Mountain – the last two names on her
list . But if Arya succeeds, what happens
next?
Can Arya live without her family?
The Starks say that “the pack survives”,
but “the lone wolf dies” . The Hound also
has unfinished business – he wants to kill
his brother the Mountain, and he’s suggested
before that he and Arya could do it together.
He mentions how Arya once left him for dead
when he was hurt . Maybe this time, Arya will
mercy kill her friend.
Bronn turns up at Winterfell, and threatens
Tyrion and Jaime.
He was sent north by Cersei who offered him
a castle if he kills her brothers.
But Tyrion offers Bronn a better castle – Highgarden,
the capital of the Reach.
It’s a ridiculously rich prize for a sellsword
like Bronn, but Bronn argues that every great
house was founded by some cutthroat, and he’s
not wrong – when the Tyrells took Highgarden,
they were just opportunistic stewards.
And House Lannister is said to have been founded
by Lann the Clever, who used a combination
of trickery sex and butter to take Casterly
Rock.
So Tyrion promises to give Bronn Highgarden,
a promise that he’d probably can’t keep.
Like, even if Daenerys wins her war, why would
she agree to give one of the most important
castles to the cutthroat who threatened Tyrion
and shot her dragon last season?
Bronn walks away satisfied with this empty
promise, even though his complaint in the
first place is that all he’s got from the
Lannisters is empty promises.
The whole Bronn arc this season seems pointless,
so why’s it in here?
In a recent interview, George Martin said
that sometimes TV networks demand more of
a popular character even if they’re not
relevant to the story – and the video implies
that he’s talking about Bronn . So maybe
that’s why Bronn’s prominent this season.
Jon farewells Tormund.
He and the wildlings are going back beyond
the Wall, and Jon sends Ghost along with them.
This loyal direwolf survived a cavalry charge
on the dead last episode, but now Jon gives
him away without so much as a pat.
This represents Jon breaking away from his
Stark identity – or maybe it just represents
that the wolves are annoying to film . Tormund
says Jon would be happier beyond the Wall,
that’s he’s got the “real North” in
him – some of Jon’s only moments of real
happiness were beyond the Wall with Ygritte.
Jon says he wishes he could go north with
Tormund , and Tormund says “You never know”.
There are theories about Jon’s story ending
in the north – as a Night’s Watchman,
or a white walkery person, or just some sad
duty so can get back to brooding in the snow
– which is what Jon was always good at.
Maybe in the end, Jon will return north, and
Ghost will get the pats he deserves.
Jon farewells Sam and Gilly.
Gilly is pregnant with their kid, and she
says they’ll name him after Jon . Thrones
journalist Joanna Robinson writes that this
is similar to the end of The Lord of the Rings
. The hero’s best friend named Sam gets
a happy ending – he falls in love with a
woman named after a flower, and they name
their kid after the hero.
But the hero Frodo is damaged.
He never quite heals from his wounds, so he
passes on to a distant realm.
Maybe, like Frodo, Jon will have a bittersweet
ending beyond the Wall – author George Martin
has said that the ending of Thrones will be
similar to Lord of the Rings .
Tyrion tells Varys about Jon’s Targaryen
identity, and Varys thinks Jon would be a
better ruler than Daenerys, cause he’s a
good leader, and he’s a man, which the Westerosi
prefer.
It’s pretty ridiculous that Varys turns
against Dany so suddenly.
He supported her for at least four seasons,
and for good reason.
Dany spent her whole story learning to be
a queen.
But now Varys dumps Dany for the first person
he sees with Targaryen blood and a penis.
Varys says he’s worried about Daenerys’
“state of mind” – and there is a history
of Targaryens going mad and violent, like
Dany’s father the Mad King.
But Varys didn’t care when Dany burned and
crucified innocent people in Meereen – so
why turn against her now?
Varys says his goal is to bring peace to Westeros.
But by jumping from one ruler to another so
many times, he’s contributed to chaos and
war.
Of course, the obvious solution here is for
Jon and Daenerys to get married, to combine
their claims.
But Varys dismisses the marriage idea . The
story won’t let Jon and Dany have such a
simple happy ending.
The Targaryen fleet reaches Dragonstone, and
suddenly, Euron 360 noscopes the dragon Rhaegal
with scorpion bolts from ships that he’d
hidden behind a rock.
He demolishes Dany’s fleet, captures Missandei,
and kills the dragon.
So in one scene, this fucking discount Jack
Sparrow does as much damage to Daenerys as
the Night King managed in the entire Long
Night.
And Daenerys should’ve seen this coming.
She’s been sneak attacked by Euron’s fleet
before.
Her dragons have been shot with scorpions
And this all happens at Dragonstone, right
on Cersei’s doorstep.
One of the advantages of dragons is that you
can see threats from miles away, so how did
she not see Euron’s eleven ships?
Daenerys suffers a terrible loss, and it doesn’t
feel earned or meaningful, it feels like a
stupid implausible fuckup.
At least it’s finally confirmed that Varys
is a mermaid.
Daenerys wants to retaliate by attacking King’s
Landing, and Varys warns her again that that
would kill thousands of innocents.
Varys looks her in the eye and says she’s
making a mistake . Cause Varys promised last
season that he would warn Dany if he loses
faith in her . And Dany had promised that
she would burn Varys he betrays her . It’s
starting to look likely that that’ll happen.
Daenerys says it’s her destiny to free the
world from tyrants . Maybe the way she’ll
fulfil that is by destroying the Iron Throne,
a symbol of tyranny.
Varys is worried by Dany’s talk of destiny
. People like Melisandre have done terrible
fiery things in the name of destiny.
But it also seems like destiny saved everyone’s
ass in the Long Night.
Whether for good or for evil, Dany’s destiny
surely involves fire.
Daenerys takes Tyrion’s advice and faces
Cersei at King’s Landing.
Realistically, Cersei would just murder them
all on sight, but that wouldn’t make for
interesting drama.
Qyburn comes out to talk, like the Mouth of
Sauron, but he won’t listen to Tyrion’s
attempts at compromise.
So Tyrion approaches Cersei directly, saying
that Cersei’s not a monster, that she should
surrender to save herself and her unborn child.
Cersei has lied and betrayed Tyrion over and
over, but Tyrion still wants to believe that
he can save his sister.
Cersei is moved by his words, but she’s
too proud and hateful to back down.
Cersei executes Missandei.
And it’s tragic that Missandei dies wearing
chains.
Daenerys freed Missandei from slavery.
But Cersei takes Missandei’s freedom as
well as her life.
Grey Worm is heartbroken and furious – Missandei
was everything to him.
But no one is angrier than Daenerys.
Cersei has killed Dany’s closest friend,
and killed Rhaegal, one of her children as
Mother of Dragons.
She’s just lost Jorah, and half her armies
last episode, and her allies plot against
her behind her back.
Daenerys has waited seven seasons to take
the Throne, and now she’s ready to burn
anything in her way – Missandei’s last
word is dracarys, which means fire.
So will Daenerys burn King’s Landing in
a fury, like her father the Mad King?
Will Daenerys become the tyrant she came to
destroy?
And will her allies do?
Will Varys undermine Dany?
Will Tyrion stay loyal?
Will Jon have to put down his love?
It would be a depressing ending if seven seasons
of Daenerys’ rise to power ends in her going
crazy and getting killed.
But Dany’s actress has hinted that she’s
not happy with the ending . Next episode will
be bloody fiery and dark.
This season of Thrones is full of dragons
and armies and magic, but sometimes the most
powerful force in the story is information.
The secret of Jon’s Targaryen identity could
end Dany’s quest for the Throne.
And Varys has always known the power of secrets
– “Secrets are worth more than silver
or sapphires, Varys claimed”.
In the books, Varys’ motivations run much
deeper than just helping the realm.
He and Illyrio have personal stakes in a complex
conspiracy involving Targaryens, the Golden
Company and dangerous secrets.
You can start the book series for free today
by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get a book each month, and if you
cancel, you keep the books.
You can read in the car or the gym or while
you sit on your boat taking pot shots at dragons.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching.
We’re holding livestreams right after each
episode of Thrones, and Patrons can watch
past livestreams.
Thanks to Ertac Altinoz for the artwork, and
thanks to the Patrons, including Sam Lundin
of House Vimbly, first of his name, Lord of
Union Square, and Protector of the Realm,
thanks to Peter Meehan, Maria Isabel Mendonça,
Sigma927, Caitlin E Wilson, malina Cureton,
and kamakazi, cheers.